they're both idiots they're both idiots
yeah we're more like Beavis than
butthead I guess so so that's pink in
the brain I'm the one with the big brain
on the left and even though I'm taller
you're and I'm like yeah that's right
pinky I watched you don't seem pinky in
the brain no I think I think the
original find the kid uh OG fans the
throwback yeah the rider dies yes are
gonna enjoy this I think so too I think
you just got to kill Christian then it's
really the original four cat's been here
four years that's true if we bring Evan
the beard back I don't know what he's
doing I wonder what he's doing it's good
man I miss having the dude he's a short
King we've always had he was a shortcut
he was a short King too it's not by it's
not by you know I don't just hire short
people you just like to Tower over
people ah isn't that weird like most of
the stuff but I mean I don't know Mike's
big just give him a shove around
oh there's that Evan oh there he is
he got married no that's someone to a
guy just kidding he's officiating just
kidding if you're listening this he's
not gay he's officiating uh the big
lease to make things a fish for my
brother oh there you go in late news I
guess I'm the weather look it's like his
brother but that's good uh my brother
hasn't my brother the guy I know very
well 11 looks just the same 2019 though
hey is Evan Casey with a beard it's a
not a bad not a bad call hold on but his
brother is uh Filipino yes I guess his
brother as in my brother you know my
brother is his brother also in the new
Batman with Tom Holland well I just did
you watch the who knows that one who
gets that reference Spider-Man what I
say Batman yeah did you see go to go to
the rest of his profile what's he up to
before we move on B let's see what the
[ __ ] Evan's doing so this is 2019 though
so he hasn't posted since 2019. oh he
got out of the game Evan was great oh
we've seen these pictures a long time
ago he was great everyone's great you
know what's funny about Evan you know so
Fox was just like podcast the [ __ ] is
that yeah here's a guy who listens to
music and like remember we were leaving
Evan wanted to come but he's like I
really don't know Sound Engineering dude
that's not my dick like yeah I have no
idea he had no idea he just figured it
out and was that when Chen came up and
said yeah when we were leaving yep dude
you just dropped you just dropped him uh
a thumb drive and said I'm your guy
which is very out of character for a
chance it's very very careful BTS of you
very impressive yeah look at it look at
us now dude BTS Chin's one you look at
him one of the owners of thick boy
Studios look at him he deserves the
stockholders he's he is a um a man who
just is consistent he's he's if and I'm
not saying I'm as smart as Steve Jobs
but if Steve Jobs started Apple yeah I
start thick boy he's my Mike wakanowski
over there whatever the [ __ ] his name is
yeah Mike what now what was my
pronounced it was not was an Oscar or
something like that he was like the
brains behind was chop ski or some [ __ ]
the guy Seth uh or the guy that uh is
from uh what's his name
yeah you're my Steve Wozniak chin but
you're way skinnier Steve Wozniak you're
my Steve Wozniak I'm Steve Jobs hey okay
let's get not get twisted definitely not
smart and much nicer Steve and I also
use deodorant yeah Steve Jobs was uh was
a prickly a bit of a man prickly pear I
call him a man cactus okay
there he was looked at this chin tall
now in a wheelchair no he's bawling he
was just doing some [ __ ] interview
he's so rich yeah he's stupid he's got
some cash look there's me and Chin those
are those guys are implied in Playa
Vista he was on someone's gonna
Photoshop me and Chin there wow
look at that hey let's call what is two
ugly dudes huh but smart
well but uh definitely strange hair and
strangers back in the day oh before we
go on I know we're joking it's the
original fireworks and stuff like that I
told this fan that I met in Phoenix I
would do this so he came it's gonna be a
little sad that's all right so here
comes the meet and greet right and uh he
had a thick boy bike club hat on and I
said oh that was my favorite hat man we
sold out of those uh glad you got one he
goes it's not my hat it was my uh I
think brother or cousin I think he said
brother try to get this right now I know
big difference your brother I know damn
it either way he's related to him you
were listening with half an ear well
it's you know you mean [ __ ] thousand
people but it's either a brother or
cousin either way you relate to him yeah
he'll say brother for this let's say
Brothers can be much more important yeah
so he goes he was my little brother's
hat and he goes he was your biggest fan
man and I were he's like I've never
listened to podcasts I've never seen you
stand up I came tonight in honor of him
I said okay and he goes he died
uh last year two years ago and I go oh
I'm so sorry man and you know I was like
covid yeah yeah two years yeah I went
coven and he he uh he was well he was
the military and I was like abort but
then I guess he was on a motorcycle and
just got hit by a car so it's his
birthday today the gentleman passed away
his name is Christian Shane Stewart and
he was born on April 20th 1989. he did
died July 24th 2021 and uh one years old
yeah man So Gone Too Soon hopefully
you're still up there listening this
[ __ ] having some laughs my man wow
man but shout out to the guy who came to
the show him his wife were so nice and
he asked me if I'd do that and I said
absolutely my man so here's to you man
yeah Christian Shane Stewart yeah real
badass man vintage fighter yeah a lot of
data do it on too not bad the the
throwback the throwback now now the boys
are a little older it's like when you
watch The Reunion of friends yeah I know
oh wow Chandler's put on a lot of weight
well oh oh what's the other guy's name
Chandler uh oh yeah oh Chandler is a
raging alcoholic and just learning his
words I saw I saw a clip of uh I showed
you that clip of of you and I with Rogan
when you were still you know I didn't
hear that what happened 2000 you know
1989 I don't no it was literally like I
tried 2014 fighting 2014. maybe earlier
yeah your voice was higher your nose was
like thinner
yeah so weird how your face changes it's
just [ __ ] weird still coming with the
heat though coming with heat come with
heat but like I I went I remember you
said uh you know I had this I had to
tell a story about being this girl in
high school told me that I you know I
wish your stomach was a little tighter
and since then I've always wanted you
know I've always been a little insecure
and then you hear me go well let's get
over that though huh yeah let's get over
that right now I've been all serious
yeah yeah and Eddie can't stop laughing
yeah no Rogan couldn't stop laughing
Eddie and Rogan Eddie's on there oh yeah
Eddie's on there [ __ ] man if I seems
like forever ago huh it was it was but
it also seems like five months ago oh it
doesn't seem like five months ago I
remember it but yeah it just seems
forever I don't remember it you know it
seems [ __ ] do you meet people from
six seven eight years ago that you don't
remember at all
I mean not real I'll never forget a face
I'll always be like like when I do those
mean greets I could be like yes it'd be
like six years ago yes and I'm like we
know each other he's like yeah dude I
Met You in Charlotte and I'm like yeah I
knew it dude certain faces your computer
you just go oh yeah yeah never will
remember a name definitely remember her
face yep yeah it's very strange right it
is weird man I was just doing a uh you
know because today starts the pr tour
for my special that drops next Thursday
April 28th on thick boy YouTube The
Gringo poppy so today starts the gamut
of uh promotion so I started with Bert
Kreischer I went to Bert's house dude
well I you know I haven't been a bird
style first done well probably I haven't
been to Bridge South probably two or
three years yep because he wasn't like
he was okay it was all right he was like
always construction we podcast out of
the his [ __ ] pool house is weird yeah
bro
he's done he's done well he's selling
some tickets
well he's selling all the tickets
nobody's better it might be wild
nobody's better permission taking all my
you're taking all the tickets he's
taking all the tickets people have to
choose and they're choosing bird overs
rightfully so he's hilarious that's fine
dude out of you know out of anybody's
house I've ever been to you name it
nobody has a Doper crib than Burt I
won't tell you where it's at I nobody
has a Doper crib than Bird yeah I worked
on my way holy oh you you've arrived
daddy made a movie and now look at you
Daddy arrived sometimes you arrive and
sometimes you arrive and then it you
things go a little bit South and you
gotta you gotta arrive again you gotta
build it up again that's all that's how
it happens sometimes it's a slow burn
sometimes that's the slow spring because
I'm gonna say you arrived right right
never arrived right like not like Burton
Tom no no you would say maybe in maybe
two years ago with the TV show maybe two
TV shows and selling great and like
things were pretty good yeah like you
know money money was and then and then
things but then there's some factors
that's why I'm saying some factors covet
inflation sure the job market like it's
a comment and then I also remember too
even three years ago be or even before
then when we're doing fine kids live and
selling out you know Vic theater and
doing all this crazy [ __ ] remember at
the time there there wasn't that many
podcasters well everybody and no one had
a podcast I mean no we were one of the
rich our agents didn't know what a
podcast my agents were like wait you
make money on your podcast nobody was
talking about podcasts no and then also
CA has a huge Branch now you're welcome
I started yeah anyway
um but yeah so at the time especially
back when we started a not many Comics
had a podcast Rogan was doing we were
doing there wasn't that many that was
almost it yeah and then now there's a
ton and they're also Comics too and
they're really good so now it's
competitive you know like if let's say
you're in I'm randomly talking if you're
in Philly next week and just Steph knows
there the week before you know for a
regular family it's tough to go back to
back weekend yeah it is and get to go
back go back clubs or whatever it's hard
to sell tickets at the end of the day
yeah you just you know you just gotta
change your game up yeah different
approach yep it's just a different game
well I'm excited about shooting the
special
yeah May 19th right improv and then uh
with my special guest and then uh just
gonna start putting things produced by
thick boy start using YouTube
yeah you know yep yep see what happens
be good man yeah boy the business is
changing so much I feel like changes a
lot it's just always evolving you know
but it seems like it's evolving like
from when I started like for the first
20 years of my career it was you know 25
years almost like 20 years it was all
the same channels same power structure
same channels that's not good though say
no but it was it was there was success
people had a career there was a way to
do it right sure and then New Media
comes along and revolutionizes literal
area and thank God because now you don't
have those Gatekeepers who they decide
what's funny who can have a career and
now guys well really on your money back
then I don't care who you were now you
you know when you when you can curate
that many tickets holy [ __ ] there were
probably one or two Comics that sold
like that yep now it's like now there's
a there's a bunch and thank God yep but
yeah so I started the pr tours but the
Pod won't come out to next week before
the special after the special
but this is my schedule and you know I
posted this on Instagram story uh for
the first time ever I had to cancel a
show it is the one night at the
Paramount Theater in Austin I'm not
doing it I'm gonna have a new date for
you guys and I'll be there for three
nights yeah you'll be happy in Austin
I'm coming back to Austin yeah they
never sat well with you that the doing a
doing a um I can speak for you on this
one because it might be a little
uncomfortable but doing a festival was
something you were doing for someone
else almost like as a favor and you were
leaving a lot of money on the table and
um and I I just know from experience at
festivals don't do anything for you no
no they do less than nothing but it man
is it a blessing and you know I'm good
with uh Moon Town we're all good there
and obviously the fans to see me soon
I'll be doing three shows so there's
gonna be more dates for you but you know
as a dad I hate leaving my kids for a
long period of time so I'd been gone
this weekend and then Wednesday I fly to
Austin I'm doing shows with Rogan
Wednesday night Thursday I do Rogan's
pod to blast out the drop of the special
and then I fly back to LA for a day and
then fly to New York to do all the you
know schultzy into Stefano and garyvee
and Barstool just blown the special up
and I fly from New York to Charlotte on
tour Thursday Friday Saturday it's a
long time for the new tour called the
trash Panda 2022. the trash trash Panda
tour oh it's no longer thick boy it's a
whole new hour daddy why is it called
the trash Panda why not all right I like
trash Panda I like it yeah I'm playing
around with some names for the special I
think I have your name and I've told you
this yeah I think I think so too I think
it's kind of outrageous we'll wait on it
because we don't want people to I think
it's a good night take it and trademark
it and whatever make it difficult on you
so you don't want to say that out loud
that's right yeah we'll see what happens
but maybe yes take a little break from
this throwback firing the kid dude you
know art dude I know you know our daddy
I'm an artist you're an artist well I
mean yeah I've been known as Scott
and draw some stuff with paint but I'm
not the thing about when you're not
playing very rare and when you're we're
Picasso you you're it only goes up in
value from what I understand yeah man
can I talk about investing listen sure
you know your boy invest in stock and
crypto and I got Sucker Punch just like
everybody out there yeah but thank God I
have Masterworks in my corner they help
normal guys like you and me all right
diversify their portfolio with blue chip
art from Masters
Monet basketball what is a lot of
there's a these are these are art pieces
that are here to stay so valuable and
listen dude here's the thing daddy the
ultra wealthy I've done it for a century
so why not us man when you realize Blue
Chip art prices outpace the S P 500 by
164 that's correct for the last 25 years
it makes sense to me man that's nuts
listen we're gigantic fans of mass Works
which is wise dude I mean like the dream
where do I start like cool stuff clemer
don't stop here go on if I won please
don't put me
yeah and then there's the other one Andy
Warhol there's there's the soup can from
Andy Warhol wow they're all of that for
oh we're joking around the I know two
wealthy people who were a long story
crazy they were told they were crazy for
actually investing in art and now there
were Millions no say trillions look over
330 000 members get Priority Access to
Masterworks with with unique links uh
we'll give you one Masterwork
masterworks.com nope
go to
masterworks.org fighter I knew you're
gonna mess that up it is tricky though
it's I do so many reads a week it is
tricky that's massworks dot art slash
fighter see important disclosures at
masterworks.io disclaimer that's
Masterworks dot art slash fighter hey B
if you're gonna work out a lot didn't
get your sweat on like when I was doing
the Tough Mudder the thick aka the thick
Mudder yeah I work out every day I'm on
my bike or I'm at zoo culture give me
something it's got sugar coloring
artificial ingredients gluten I don't
want any fillers I don't want that what
are you gonna talk to me about just shut
your old dry pipe dude if it's an
electrolyte drink mix I'm just saying it
can't have sugar yeah yeah and dude
element this tasty tasty electricity
Yes Man okay they get a lot of salt with
no sugar it contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio all right okay a lot
of sodium a lot of potassium a lot of
magnesium with none of the junk no sugar
no coloring no artificial sweeteners no
BS all right we got got you man when you
sweat you're losing electrolytes man you
can cramp up it's not the best way to do
it you get headaches oh my god dude
elements used by moms dads brothers
sisters aunts NBA NFL NHL players Navy
Seals anyone who wants to get their
workout on element is so sure you're
going to love their product and come
back for more they're offering the fire
and kid listeners and viewers and
element sample pack that's eight single
serving packets free should cover the
cost of shipping it's five bucks all
right for the US customers get yours at
drinklmnt.com fighter this deal is not
available on all their regular websites
it's not dude you must go to drink
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t.com slash fighter
element offers no questions asked
refunds either so totally risk down like
a chair with a salty friend and we'll
give you your money back no questions
asked you have nothing to lose but yeah
so it's a blessing that moon tower uh
didn't work out because I can stay home
and I'll miss as much time with the
kiddos that would be a [ __ ] dude let
me ask you this you did a food truck
diary with Patty pimblet well you know
me yeah I hate to you know get out of my
comfort zone as far in L.A well yeah
drive down to San Diego uh no at 6am I
had to wake up at five that's outrageous
so but now now I have before you go on
he looks about as big as you are now why
he's a 155er and he's a 155. that's a
big kid what's he what did he weigh
right right over 200 what dude he's hey
he's the funniest guy I've had on the
show is he he's so great he is such a
like great Vibe about him and he's not
you know it's a similar economy first
came out like he's not cocky yeah he's
just he's he believes it yeah and he's
fun about it yep he was talking about uh
I go I said well you're the uh you're
the original thick boy dude how much do
you weigh right now you're the original
thick Boy from Liverpool he goes I don't
know I haven't weighed myself let's
assure you guys I get a gut though I go
dude you're getting so big between
fights like we have to ask you to take a
short nose fight he goes what
is who take I wish I could do with that
thing is who takes shorts fights he goes
why would I do that he just doesn't make
sense he goes I make more money outside
the Octagon he goes you want me to take
a short notice right for what because I
don't need the money he's like but he's
not talking to me he's the first guy to
do this so you know he's a performer he
would when I when he would like go off
on those fun things look at the camera
and perform for the camera wow this
kid's a beast yeah how old is he uh 27.
wow amazing and then you know I brought
up the but it's weird I brought up like
the criticism of him you know I'm like
you know
the two like biggest prospects and
you'll see are Hamza and you yeah and
obviously with you compared to Hamza no
not even that I'm not talking about
skill set I said you know in your first
two fights you've gotten hit he goes
yeah that's on purpose
he's like I have to get hit to wake up
he's like my coach is like hey man we
can't keep doing this he's like when
those fights just had no respect for him
I know it's going to start them so he's
like I you know I wanted to make it
exciting for the fans so I knew I was
gonna freaking get hit and dude and then
his here's the thing so we had Vulcan
Oscar on which aired today on food truck
if you're listening uh the Alex
volcanovsky food truck in El Camino
um where we uh ate arapas it it it
[ __ ] started today
um
he uh
oh there he has a great [ __ ] clip but
um
we so he gave marapas out of a El Camino
so but the the thing about
um volkanovsky and Patty is you know
these crazy success stories and they're
making all this money outside the UFC
it's because they have great [ __ ]
managers man yeah their managers are the
best I've ever worked with really like
this guy Graham for uh Patty yeah uh
Graham he he I didn't know this he lives
in San Diego that's why Patty's there he
flies out there because his manager
loser but his manager is also the owner
of cage Warriors do you know anything
about cage Warriors let me tell you some
of the alumni and he's owned it and
started it for 15 years wow cage
Warriors is where Conor McGregor came
out of was a champion there okay Michael
Bisping oh Dan Hardy Jesus uh Tom
aspinall Darren till ever heard of that
oh yeah Pat dude Patty was making more
in cage Warriors way more than he is in
the UFC damn that's why the UFC after
him twice and he turned it down because
he makes more money I didn't realize how
big of a star he is yeah in in the UK
everywhere I didn't know I like I knew
he's big yeah he refers to himself as
the fifth Beatle because the Beetles are
from Liverpool it's so funny his
haircut's the same refers himself as a
fist Beetle Liverpool yeah from
Liverpool but he uh isn't Darren till
from Liverpool now Darren tell my people
no no Darren Darren tells from Liverpool
okay yeah that's a rough some rough cats
out there oh you go he goes the weather
[ __ ] the weather [ __ ] I think you like
it he's like tan like no you're not
um but he uh
yeah so in going back to how big of a
star is in Liverpool like he he's Tom
Cruise out there man Jesus and so like
you know he sold out that O2 Arena well
he didn't sell out the UFC did man I was
I was saying on the shop show I was
talking to his manager about I'm like
yeah I thought he'd have like UFC
Jitters like it's a big [ __ ] deal yo2
Arena and he goes oh he sold out three
times before the UFC though on his own
he's like he was like I think it might
have sold out he's not only used to the
hype he's just a hype at home where if
he loses it's way more he loves it
devastating but he but uh
me and Graham were talking he goes I
think he probably would have sold out
would have sold out in eight minutes
he's like three isn't sold out so fast
it was because of Patty Jesus Christ so
I you I didn't realize and dude Patty's
making Leaps and Bounds more money than
he makes inside the UFC not even close
so crazy
so he's like why fight yeah he's like
he's like I love to fight he's like so
I'll do it and hopefully we can agree on
a contract but and he was also like I'm
and that's what I love about him he's
like I'm not in a rush either he's like
I'll get those you think they'll bring
him up slowly yeah 100 yeah just like
they did with sugar shot yeah what's his
Camp he's still he's fighting in
Liverpool yeah yeah same camp yeah where
you yeah he walked in the gym I think he
said he was 16 or 17 and never left geez
he's a [ __ ] monster man such a good
kid such a good yeah dude humble they
don't let you get away with [ __ ] even if
you're a star you got to stay humble
he's great yeah when he ordered the
Bergens one of the best burgers we've
ever had on the show and it came it's
called swagu Uh Food Truck Yeah so I did
you know because we had a day notice to
get down to San Diego like Patty's like
he he was like hey I've been standing
I'm like dude
um my Show's in L.A he's like ah man
it's too far you know we have our
schedule I'm like let me see if I can
find a [ __ ] Trucking venue to do it
down there so I hit up the team but then
I did a Instagram story post and and we
need a food truck and this swagu food
truck Jesus Christ we dude we've never
had more people blow us the [ __ ] up
probably 150 fans like swagoo swagu
swagu damn it was fantastic that that
Burger's stupid right and Patty ate that
but he had I think three or four Patties
on it oh my God Patty's for Patty damn
that looks delicious dude it was so good
because wagyu beef yes oh and all that
fat dude in the bun yeah that bun looks
did I [ __ ] my pants on the way home yeah
of course she did like that basically
fat between two pieces of wheat oh it
was nice and Patty kept going this is
heavy oh mate this is heavy and I went
hey I stopped my hey I don't I don't
know the lingo in Liverpool does heavy
mean like it's gonna be heavy in your
stomach he's like no Heavies like means
a lot of things like he's like heavy
like good yeah like this is heaven all
right ridiculously good yeah oh it was
[ __ ] [ __ ] so so the food truck just
happened to work out you have Italian
who's a huge guest so you have the best
food truck we've ever had it's shout out
to swagyu and then also I you know to do
the sit down portion I need somewhere
quiet where we can sit down that's why
doing thick Laugh Factory Duce I hit up
and Reiki Enrique at Laugh Factory and
was like hey man I don't I know you guys
aren't open at [ __ ] 9 A.M on a
Tuesday is it cool if we use this he's
like hell yeah dude so they let us in so
we did on the stage there it just worked
out perfect we didn't hit traffic you
just talk for
over I mean by the time they edited it
probably you know 40 minute show it's
fantastic oh we could win all day but he
did have to get going he's like mate
live a cool place in 30 minutes hey you
going I was like oh they do he's like
yeah yeah so I can drink I gotta find a
pub
he's giving his manager [ __ ] because the
manager he's not uh from Liverpool I
think he's from uh he's Welsh or
something he's like mate I don't give a
[ __ ] about soccer he's like everyone
will be watching could be the most
exciting the World Cup and my back
turned to it just [ __ ] staring out he
said that or the manager the manager
yeah Patty's like super yeah soccer is a
[ __ ] religion people sing songs they
go crazy yeah they it the whole thing's
a nightmare I told him I was like I'd be
down to go but I'm worried about
Hooligans he's like he was like you
[ __ ] America well no like no he goes
yeah there's no more Hooligans no he's
like they they have listed eradicated he
goes let's say he goes this is how they
got rid of it he goes and it's basically
what we did with the RICO Act with the
mafia and I hate to compare them to
Mafia yeah but they just make it's so
strict if they do something that they're
so [ __ ] that they just go away so he
was like back in the day
you know if you're in a fight in England
you know you [ __ ] somebody up you can
get thrown in jail man it's not good
he's like but if you're gonna fight at a
soccer game and you're fighting with
another uh like a clan like if it's a
Hooligans he's like dude it's like a
felony oh yeah he's like so they just
quit fighting that's what they did
exactly they all got locked up yeah in
Ireland too they just they would
literally gangster just me they'd be
fighting before they got to the [ __ ]
stance that's what he said and bad stuff
there's a book called among the thugs
yep and the reporter who just talked
about the [ __ ] that they would do they
were doing like paint their face and
[ __ ] and they know they stab people they
give you that smile Joker yeah they do
all kinds of [ __ ] to you man just gang
up on you and stomp you the battery was
like this people were getting killed oh
yeah for sure you're getting killed
because you like man not just men not
just men women too really women were
fighting too they were getting [ __ ] up
Jesus they do with a guy and they'd get
[ __ ] stomped too really bad really
bad Patty was laughing he's like you
[ __ ] Americans like what's the market
out here dude they scare us like Mexico
I'm wondering about cartels [ __ ]
London I go to Premier League everybody
getting shank by hooligan that doesn't
happen you have a great time with the
game like calm down dude yeah and he
goes it's from he referenced a movie
Kyle knows it with uh Austin Powers Fat
Bastard
is that what it was I know no no no no
I'd love to go I know it's some movie
about Hooligans
because uh like Manchester awesome
powers like my my brother-in-law's a
huge Manchester hey Carl man united I
forget what movie but oh Ethan Hawke is
in it Green Street
um Elijah Wood yeah that's it okay yeah
Green Street was what Patty's talking
about
yeah I've never seen it two out of five
he goes oh you probably saw Green Street
and that's why you're scared I was like
I've never heard of that movie yeah he's
like it's kind of good
yep but I apparently that's about
Hooligans how's the guy from Sons of
Anarchy in it
I've never seen it and no I'd see it I'd
watch it but dude between Alex
volkanovsky and then [ __ ] Patty two
of my favorite food trucks that's pretty
badass
good people
yeah get what burns coming in huh we got
Gilbert Burns coming next week too um
they're a coming man that's a beast yeah
you built it up yeah yeah they come yeah
a little different than when I was at
Showtime because they'd handle all the
travel and hotels did you see now Daddy
has saved the new Batman
uh dude I'm so glad you brought that I
watched it last night yeah me too you
watched it with my son don't tell me are
you watch me he would be dark yeah too
dark for 10 years old son 10 years old
Michael Keaton Batman Brian I thought it
was now what are you doing and now the
kids don't make that now the kid won't
leave my side he goes I was scared last
night I was going to the kitchen because
where are you going I go I'm going to
the kitchen he's not with the new
Riddler that [ __ ] is scary so realistic
but also I mean what the [ __ ] though no
I didn't see it in on King's thing in
the wing Eric Griffin's like super balls
deep into like comic book movies Theo
and saw it yeah dark this is the problem
listen to like comments or your people
and their opinions that aren't yours
they told me oh it's bad it's too long
it's boring
first of all Amazon it is the best
Batman that's ever been made it's
amazing it's right up there with the
Dark Knight dude I looked at my girl 30
minutes and I went is this not the best
[ __ ] movie we've seen in years
it's very oh it's about to pass a
billion dollars it's crushing yeah
that's a very but I'm saying people's
opinions on it and I'm like how slow
they go too long and then people go oh
it's too long I wish it was longer how
about that dude Lord of the Rings is too
long you [ __ ] Batman and also I hate the
interrupted the new Batmobile yeah 100
it's a throwback [ __ ] Dodge
Challenger on steroids I think he's
great I thought he was fantastic he's
fantastic like I think his darkness and
just like he's so vulnerable and so
[ __ ] up and trying to find Faith
somewhere he's also re like he's real
you know what I'm saying like real as
[ __ ] and The Riddler you know is this
basically like a troll that turns to
this murderer he's killing politicians
it's so real the movie's so real the
real Riddler was horrifying oh you you
know they uh there's a edit it's out now
but he go he meets with the new Joker in
prison and obviously this is they're
doing it more like real so the Joker's
like this insane madman whose Skin's all
[ __ ] up because he scratched his skin
yeah but I watched the the edit uh the
deleted clip last night that joke I
don't know who it is it's not like
somebody Super Famous they do that for a
reason it looks [ __ ] crazy really the
new Joker looks nutso and he's gonna be
making an appearance yeah well they edit
it out so I I I have 20 minutes left to
move so I don't know if they uh tease
the Joker but I know that part is edited
out dude yeah finish that movie oh
really yeah I have 20 minutes I was too
tired last night okay because I I didn't
realize what the [ __ ] was going on I'm
watching with my son and I went this is
dark and I looked at my son I go are you
all right with this he goes I'm fine Dad
I'm fine meanwhile you [ __ ] kid would
not leave my [ __ ] side you [ __ ] up
that was bad he's too young to watch the
movie way too young too young and I was
scared but it was so well so my guns out
last night so well done oh my shot star
set design defy everything about it if
you're a film person which I'm actually
not it's it's it's hard to deny Catwoman
King get it now let's hold on now hold
on now
hold on daughter first of all first of
all when dude when her excuse me
hey
dude hey dude
and I'm being dead serious now look me
in the eye
don't talk about my girl you're right
that's my girl okay no Noah share Monday
Wednesday Friday Tuesday Thursday
Saturday bro Sundays now listen to me
dude she's so hot you know she's tiny
though that's my girl she's tiny I think
she's five foot she is her and Cat would
have a [ __ ] I love her I love her so
much after that is she not is she not
the most beautiful because she might so
wait you're five two and that's a
Hollywood five two because Robert
Patterson's not well I like her more now
because I like petite that's like tiny
oh my gosh she's so hot dude and she was
born in Venice
I remember her as a little girl I used
to see her I would go to uh don't act
like that and see her well you know
you're every Sunday well now she was
like I did but now she's like oh Brian
Kellen thinks I'm hot and she probably
listen this and then you go I remember
as a little girl oh he's out you're out
I know that's what I thought of myself I
was like I can't even like and you get
to a certain age you can't even stare
you're a creep
that's the problem but I I love her not
movies I love her oh because she's and
you know what I like about uh the the
way they told her story who the [ __ ] is
that I don't know who the [ __ ] is this
that's Donald Glover oh I love him
that's okay her boyfriend's Channing
Tatum oh well there you go okay I mean
so
I'm so heartbroken right now why do you
compete with channels I mean there's not
many names you're throwing he's a great
guy there's not many names you could
throw out there that would make me feel
insecure that'll do it that'll be super
talented and yeah and also a great guy
and a big guy now now hold on big but
yeah now hold on
uh she is uh like think about what it
was like she grows up with the coolest
parents on the planet and the most
beautiful parents on the planet and very
talented parents and then she gets the
best of both of them in a way like look
at her
like look at her oh she's gorgeous like
you're just touching you're blessed oh
my God
again when her and uh Batman kiss
my girl looked over I was like this
that's my that's my girl okay that's my
girl now you're too old dude and by the
way
bring up bring up uh um
and Lisa just broke up with uh Jason
Momoa yeah they were together forever
which was Mo is a dime piece too though
look at her place on there yeah he was
there with his daughter he's cool and
looking in person a single person
started losing their [ __ ] when he came
to the stadium Arena holy take a look at
her they look well that's exactly how
she's gonna look when she's hurt that's
right look at them come on some people
just are they don't have their own kids
huh
because that is just mimoas Jason Momoa
and Lisa uh Bonet have two kids oh they
do oh I bet those kids are gorgeous let
me see those kids they're cute they're
such good looking people man I want to
see somewhere around like 10 and 11. I
always love the story Jason Moore is
telling when he's on Game of Thrones and
you know one of the biggest shows of all
time and he's living in a van in Malibu
off Malibu because he wasn't making
money wow he was making that night yet
he said he got blackballed after doing
uh what was a Baywatch look at those
kids
look at her hair oh my God what do you
do what it's like they're like Sprites
you find them in a forest they're like
you look for them again they disappear
models yeah they have all the Rings they
have wings on their ankles you think
you're a kid okay they grab a little
[ __ ] is that okay they're cuter when
they're younger no they're still no
they're still gorgeous God yeah the
whole thing's a disaster well look at
their dad dude yeah times peace that's a
stud he was living in his van wow do all
the games well you know I never say I
stopped him he was at ashay so they used
to go to a restaurant that I would go to
every Sunday College if you tell me his
friend I'm gonna suck you in the face no
and he I he he was walking he went to
the bathroom came back and I you know me
he had a white T-shirt on and I just go
I was like who the [ __ ] is he's
breathtaking he's yeah breathtaking and
this was 15 years I don't know when was
Conan but bring up when Conan came out
oh the person not 15. 12 years ago 13
years ago I don't know he was so
striking I put the wrong bird out right
okay oh two on eleven B okay so so yeah
so we're talking about 11 12 years ago
so I just couldn't understand who the
[ __ ] this guy was I I could not believe
what he looked like he was such a good
looking dude and so big and I and I
stopped him yeah I go I go we're going
to the bathroom I go hold on I go who
are you and what what do you how do you
look like this I said what do you do and
he said and he goes an actor I'm an
actor he goes I'm I'm playing Conan
yeah but he was he hadn't even done the
movie so but this was 13 years ago
probably 2011. blew my [ __ ] mind I
was like you're the most we just could
everybody was looking at him no he just
he just some of those you know some
people just look like a star yeah Factor
well they're all you see certain people
when they walk through I'm like oh
you're different than the rest of us
that's cool I mean yeah you can't take
your eyes off him something like a gay
thing no you're just like god dude well
look at him you built different and then
I hung out with him one time a little
bit with me and gorilla in in Malibu
because Grillo uh Grillo new um
the guy who had done Battlestar
Galactica or whatever the [ __ ] show he
was on some sci-fi show
so we were just there and I was on the
end of the table I didn't really say
anything to him but again I was like
looking at him going who the [ __ ] how is
this guy not a huge am I the only one
who notices that this guy is striking
beyond measure are you saying you
discovered Jason Momoa I did discover
Jason I discovered him now your same
passion you had no I don't look that way
hold on you oh you know what I mean no
no no but as an actor you got there's
something about yourself
about you kind of cute I go back and I
look in the mirror and you go well in
fact I said that to him I went to the
bathroom I went to pee I looked at
myself in the mirror and I went well
that's the that's the medium white guy
and that's okay but you're not gonna do
anything on your looks no there's a lot
there's a lot people say that you're
privileged when you're a white straight
guy I'm competing with a big pool
I don't know how privileged I'm
competing with all the other white guys
yeah
yeah so now that same energy you had we
met Jason Momoa where you were like oh
my gosh so big what do you do Brian and
we don't travel together anymore but he
used to do that to any big black guy on
a plane which now would be considered
racist you go oh my get Woody in the NFL
what no yeah I'm like please don't be
what are you doing any black person hey
uh what sport
or no you're lying yeah Brian's like
full [ __ ] no but it is that big in
that proportion how about how about you
know me with when people say oh he's
athletic Bert goes uh that's how he
starts the pot off today he goes dude my
uh producer's a wrestler
I know what he was dude yeah he's a
[ __ ] legit wrestler damn uh we're
dressed at in my head I'm thinking like
Iowa or high school state and then you
know went on to you know try maybe
meddle in the National level he goes I
just wrestled two years in high school I
looked at where I went that didn't count
though does it burn he was white I
played baseball one year am I a baseball
player yeah he started laughing so hard
he's like oh I forgot dude I'm like yeah
okay I was like you tossed around the
term athlete too easily dude that was
with my girl and and we were standing in
line for the plane and behind me these
two seven foot not six eleven but six
twelve legit seven foot seven Footers
and very very muscular and very
proportioned clearly professional
basketball players and who knows and
they they came up white guys are black
black they came right behind us handsome
both handsome guys proportion when
you're purport when let's call him six
eleven six nine I don't know when you're
a proportion six nine six ten and I made
them last so hard because they just come
up behind us and I just turned on
are you serious
are you kidding and they just started
while their dick is in your face yeah
all those high level dicks in your face
you're that tall and that good looking
now do you are you in law school you
know just [ __ ] with them all right ah
you're all right man I was like yeah I
know and then I go like this I grab my
girl I go I'd like to present you with
this gift I present you guys this I'd
love to see you both run a train on her
yeah and then when we touched down she's
been with them and she ran off with them
and now you're taking care of the kids
right that's a cool story and so there
it is yep so my child is super tall and
super tall and black right skin tone
yeah yeah but uh to wrap it up that
Batman is fantastic you seen it cat yeah
I've seen it what do you think it was
amazing absolutely I love that they put
it on HBO uh Max because you know I
can't go to the movie theater you know I
got kids so when it comes I have to wait
till it hits [ __ ] on demand Jay texts
me and goes hey Batman hit HBO Max like
oh I have something to watch tonight he
looks great in that suit what do you
think of him he's he's very fast he's
amazing yeah good looking guy good actor
dude you ever seen him in Water for
Elephants no oh my God he's good enough
really because the Twilight is just you
know yeah good actor lame he's a good
[ __ ] actor dude Water for Elephants
he's fantastic really what oh uh
Christian loves Twilight oh no that's
for yeah my you know you were young when
you saw it yeah it's a different
generation people love them yeah people
love them my daughter when my daughter
took it so seriously she could barely
handle it yeah it's like well I was in I
was a freshman in high school when
Titanic came out people saw it like
seven my daughter when she was a little
girl wouldn't watch it with me because
it was so romantic to her Titanic no uh
Twilight she wouldn't watch it white man
can't jump white uh Twilight she
wouldn't watch it with me [ __ ] because I
was ruining the she was in her own
romantic world she was in love with the
Vampire so for Dad to be there it's like
dude get the [ __ ] out of here I'm having
a look I'm sure maybe the same room I'm
sure maybe I'd like it if I watched it
but I what you know sometimes it's on TV
and then it'll show like the where was
with the vampires not a like a snow like
field and they're like standing from
each other my girl was like what is this
[ __ ] man yeah magic's gone well dude
I tried uh you know I have no I've ran
out of it I've watched everything I have
nothing like I finished uh [ __ ] uh
the ultimatum have you did you finish it
I didn't finish it I won't ruin it worth
finishing oh yeah really yeah you want
to see how it ends yeah yeah it's great
okay
um so I finished that I have no show to
watch so I told my girl I'm like let's
bring True Blood back we love that
30 minutes of that first half she goes
there's some silly [ __ ] like it doesn't
stand there yes it sucks
the fairy storyline is tough oh it gets
lame it gets so bad I still didn't mind
at the time was kind of involved it's
good for when it came out sucky oh I
love that show
I remember that Suki the show's great
man I have nothing now from beauty I
have Batman uh well I can't I have to
stand up tonight so I'll finish it
tomorrow night the last 20 minutes
but you should watch that delete scene
with the Joker that new Joker is scary
oh man The Riddler was the deleted scene
online really yeah it was on Worldstar
should be on YouTube by now yeah I'm
sure it's all over YouTube
that Joker's yes yeah they make it so
real now so intense I told my girl I
look at my own like this is so intense
it's not a cartoon as much anymore can I
tell you one thing I wish about the
Batman I wish I wish that Robert
Patterson killed some of those [ __ ]
he just would beat him up I wish he
would just [ __ ] but Batman doesn't
kill well you'd have to beat him to
death or strangle because Batman doesn't
use guns right that's how you always say
no guns yeah but can you use a like a
sword or a [ __ ] shark dude that is
dark it's dark but some of those people
suck I got the Riddler was gnarly man
when he starts singing Ave Maria no
that's so good and then Montana man and
then just the way he uh you know you
take all those politicians out and it's
so real I know because they're Liars
they are but and you can say you see the
people that that the bomb around the
next episode so the cage with the rats
that's from what what what book is that
from
famous book George Orwell uh George
Orwell wrote in 1984 and that's where
it's from so it's a famous scene it's a
horrifying I read it in high school I
was like oh my [ __ ] god that's a way
to die they put a rat they put your they
put starving rats in a cage with rats
over your face see it but but I know
back in the medieval times uh these
torture people they would take one of
those like uh [ __ ] pots steel pots
and then put a big ass you know Medieval
Time rat so they're bigger they'd put it
in the [ __ ] pot yeah and then set
fire to it and then the only way the rat
he freaks out he didn't want to burn so
he chews a hole through your stomach
yeah yeah or they would put a a tube in
your ass and run rats up into your ass
with fire through rats oh got you into
your butt yeah so he said fire I'm like
all right well that ain't such a good
time either there's a lot of bad human
beings did found really great ways to
[ __ ] you over who the [ __ ]
we need whatever Ralph the third to talk
let's get one of those rats dump out
that [ __ ] chicken stew yeah let's get
[ __ ] a rat in there and we'll put
fire in it yeah and I think and they
have no idea they're just spitballing
here at this point there's brainstorming
horrible ideas he was like in hopefully
the rat realizes he can only go through
his stomach and then it worked look at
that there you go right there that's a
good time but why is the rat eat your
face off because they're starving hungry
and and and they're already starving and
they just start eating their face and
rats eat flesh sure they they are
carnivorous they will eat flesh in a
heartbeat so that's why that's why he
had the thing around the the clear tube
around the face yeah because the rat was
gonna need his face off
I feel like it would take forever too
yeah and then the other direction is
full on your nose and then like three
days go by you get a bunch of them in
there it's not fun and then and then you
have um you can only have so many
because it's crowded there's a lot hold
on you're skipping past yeah the rat
torture yeah you only have so many rats
in there if they get full eating one ear
five five six very hungry better be a
big cake Norwegian rats are big dude
break up Norwegian dude it better be a
big cage New York rats are huge yeah
that's a Norwegian uh I saw San
Francisco rad that would give me all the
business Master Splinter popped up when
I was in San Francisco doing cops the
big Norwegian rats they will name that
one ain't [ __ ] I'm not worried about him
eating my face you are if it's five or
six and they're starving they will go
right through your the old face man but
when they're bigger rats you need a lot
of room Daddy and also the tank is long
dude that's nine inches long that's a
big rat but also the tank on your head
is gonna be so heavy you have to lay
down
or you don't have to set up so you gotta
no that would make you sit like this
we're not so big you're gonna tip over
no and the rat's all good to the side no
you'll just stand like this a lot goes
into it if you think about it there's a
lock that goes into it you don't want
rats you don't want to you don't want
the cage the head cage you don't want
the head cage dude that's all I'm trying
to say you don't want you don't want the
Butt Tube or the head cage when it comes
to rats if you have a big one though
butt tuber head cage probably going Butt
Tube right uh no oh Jesus I don't know
dude rat's in your face I don't eat me
inside out Daddy I guess that's an I
don't I don't like any of us
I don't know what to do man I think head
uh I don't know they're [ __ ] terrible
I don't know what to do but that that
bomb around his neck that happened in
real life do you know that yeah there's
uh
there's a documentary on Netflix [ __ ]
crazy they met him rob a bank yeah and
he did it what a crazy boy should we do
things of course then they flew him up
oh they oh that's right afterwards they
blew him up and they found did they find
it was a woman yeah I think so right
didn't they make
no no there's a movie uh
uh uh 30 minutes or less where it was
about that too basically oh but it was a
bomb vest that was good yeah it was
obviously like bombed a little different
yeah yeah but that's what it was based
off of no this this guy real thing that
collarbomb explosion murder imagine that
dude well remember they have that thing
uh it might be Russia or China remember
they have that thing where it just wraps
under your neck and then electrically it
automatically goes this tightens up and
[ __ ] kills you they just toss around
your neck and goes automatically look at
this
that's him robbing a bank like that come
on and that [ __ ] that woman right
they found her look at that [ __ ] dude
who the [ __ ] thinks of this stuff that
this woman I forget I forget the story
but yeah there's a p the the there's
something with pizza involved right did
they deliver their Pizza lady yeah
no they just they just said they they
had him order a pizza and then they put
to know where he lives yeah and then
they put this around this neck and said
you're gonna go [ __ ] rob a bank
um it's unbelievable no one was charges
no oh no one was charged Authority
struggle to determine who was behind the
plot and whether Wells was an innocent
victim or willing participant wow this
guy's been but the case has been solved
and indictments are expected likely by
next month
um wait so they didn't solve the case
was the guy whose head blew off we know
all the details knows what happened to
the instant
was he involved
let's see did the doc say
our memories are terrible dude I'm
you know what there's so many doc
there's a new one on John Wayne Gacy
that just dropped too there is it's dark
I don't want to watch that because he's
such a horrible [ __ ] guy but um also
Jimmy Seville who was a child molester
uh if it's kids I don't [ __ ] with it
yeah
he was annoying participants oh dude it
was shown on live television
dude how about last time we're watching
that scary ass Batman dude and there's a
helicopter over my house and there's
cops up the Gazoo so I'm like online you
know if the neighbors app I'm [ __ ] on
bringing it I'm like what the [ __ ] is
happening I get the guns out me and my
girl [ __ ] Commander so we have a
AR-15s out just looking out the window
helicopter
what happened finally I text Jay I'm
like man something's going down see if
you see anything online because you know
he's [ __ ] yeah Mr Brainiac online
finally found it some guy stole a car uh
in Woodland Hills and was not on a
high-speed chase
and then he crashed uh Mulholland Drive
they got him dummy but also by the way
you need all that also has anybody ever
gotten away in a high-speed chase in Los
Angeles anybody have you ever gotten
away when helicopters when you see the
helicopters just pull over it ain't
gonna work for you that's it that's why
it's always weird on the news when I
don't know why they're obsessed with
these high-speed chases like on the 101
or the 405 and they look it's like
breaking news and they stop all news to
[ __ ] film that it's like all right
dude I love watching I don't I don't get
it the OJ when I get oh yeah it's
[ __ ] O.J Simpson yeah let's stop and
watch yes some random dude who stole a
[ __ ] Chrysler and they stopped and
Ukraine going to [ __ ] it they're like
[ __ ] Ukraine this guy that stole the
Chrysler much more important that's
right yeah that's right also dude I was
not gonna get away yeah never drive I
know how this is stop let's stop people
he's actually gonna run out of gas any
day now yeah but also just drive into a
mall parking lot helicopter cops can't
go in there and then run out and run in
the mall and then run to the mall that's
right but then if people see you they're
gonna snitch on you and always carry a
disguise but that's usually the carry
Fox wig wig hat or yeah or a wig and a
dress and also once you're in the
parking lot don't be all frantic just
act like you're parking Daddy and then
you walk in the mall and then they have
they don't know what you look like yeah
the car's there they have no there's so
many people it's a good call think about
all the time dude that's a good call
yeah thanks man and in fact then you go
and you run into one of the stores can I
use your bathroom
you climb into the duct
no you go to the bathroom you change you
look totally different
you've got a wig you shave your head
Maybe
there's a lot of things you can do we
just get lost in the crowd you get lost
in the crowd comment line it's Cinnabon
like everybody else you my heart rate
you might you might have a tough time
too big you might get well medium white
guy you're fine white guy brown hair
very easy unless you're a mall in like
Atlanta yeah where it's all black that's
true and then you go in there like yeah
the white guy yeah in line at [ __ ]
you know but in in you know any Beverly
I just I just kind of what oh you'd be
good yeah sit down at a restaurant order
some food it must be stressful dude
driving like that like you're never
getting away
well you got to think what's I don't
think those people plan you gotta plan
for like well they're already [ __ ] and
then they're probably like there's a
small chance I'm gonna get away because
I'm just some people do good away
because you because you know there's a
new rule that the cops can't chase you
notice the cops are way back now yes
they don't chase because when they used
to chase them they used to do crazy [ __ ]
and then kill innocent people so now
their new rules they're just the cops
going like 60. and that guy's going 100
the helicopters are up top
hey he's headed this way the helicopter
is all over yeah clear the road and just
put some just let him do his thing yeah
hey B you know what I was doing keto I'm
on Carnivore right now yes but I you
know your boy when I was doing keto to
do to be an actual ketosis you need some
help I need some help dude and I can't
thank my friends
all right at real ketones enough dude
because if I had this when your boy was
the keto kid yeah I would have stuck to
the diet way easier man well explain to
me experience explain to me what what
you're talking about here you go let's
keep one of the most incredible health
and wellness stuff I've ever used man
you know listen to my health your boy if
I if I'm sick I'm I'm missing shows here
I can't do that Daddy can't do that you
want to burn fat you want you want to
have more energy you want to increase
Focus you want to do things that make
you feel great right yeah and I've never
been more ripped than when I was on uh
keto man all right but you need real
ketones all right dbhb is identical to
what your body naturally makes all right
and with within one hour you're in
ketosis which is nuts and you can
monitor it right
it's absolutely incredible it's one of
the only Health Technologies on the
market that really works man whatever
your goal is energy weight loss on any
diet hydration ketosis whether keto or
not real ketones and BHB needs to be
part of your daily routine get it now I
love these guys get it now at
realketones.com use promo code Shob for
10 off that's Schaub is the promo code
if you don't love this product they give
you your money back how about that
that's real ketones.com
use promo code shop for 10 off
realketones.com beautiful on it that's
all I gotta say you got to focus all
right thank God I'll tell you what you
got to get on what they got stuff here
you got to get on your tickets because
you're in Port Charlotte and then you
also got you're in Port Charlotte then I
got wine it's Thursday Friday Saturday
yeah then I got Wise Guys in Vegas and
then I got the stress Factory in New
Brunswick New Jersey so get on that yeah
and also get on these nuts yeah just
kidding dude get on my special 30 minute
special the Gringo poppy drops next
Thursday April 28th on YouTube thick boy
Channel only that's right self-funded
all the [ __ ] the Billboards the sizzle
reels all done by my team shot by my
team the thick boy team is in the
special business what up fam come
support your boy I did it myself I
turned on every major Network you know
what's up we're doing it the Gringo
poppy 30 minutes this or next Thursday
April 28th on thick boy YouTube only uh
new tour starts so we gotta rename it so
you have trash Panda tour 2022 starts in
Charlotte that is May 5th through the
7th at the comizone in Charlotte North
Carolina and then Philadelphia trash
Panda tour continues May 19th through
May 21st get your tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com but speaking
about being on it if you're not if you
on it and go to Port Charlotte if you be
on it you can go watch yourself
nutrients you need your daily sport you
need performance you need your immune
Health you need your you've got you've
got you've got Focus you've got to focus
they got brain food for you they got
stuff for your sleep protein powders
yeah creating the best supplements oil
whey protein they got dark roast coffee
which I swear by you know this fat
Butters elk bars Warrior bars we have
Fitness streaming Fitness there's no
reason to be that thick dude on-demand
workouts on it in 30. we got home
fitness programs
quad maces battle ropes sandbags on
it.com fighter 10 off the entire goddamn
website audit.com finder 10 off yes
we'll be we'll just watch you we'll be
waiting dude imagine the OJ thing if
you're like people would jump on the
highways and watch them go by his
friends driving them unbelievable not
some [ __ ] unbelievable see one of the
most watched things ever what's he do
now OJ yeah do you follow him sure do
have a whole bid on it he's a great
follow yeah yeah the best he's Still
rocking it I mean yeah dude so you know
getting pictures with chicks and [ __ ] I
think he's in uh Vegas does he does
appearances he's in Vegas I don't he's
more he does too he's on Twitter he does
a picture he's got to be making money in
one way or another I don't know he well
he still gets I mean uh what would it
cost to rent him out for your party
the thing is do you want here's my
question here hello Twitter world would
you uh would you have OJ on the pod
I would really you know you can't talk
about murder though right so we're going
to talk about fantasy football yeah
that's what we're going to talk about
for an hour here yeah I used to talk
about his old school football days like
oh man talk about a fall for Grace so
well yeah I mean murdered two people so
you want to hear him at all are you good
ASAP Rocky arrested in connection with
2021 shooting that's one of the current
events too oh wow all right yeah yeah
what does but here's the other thing OJ
uh obviously can't make any money based
off the murder so the books his pension
but I think they get even that no I
think they couldn't touch the 300 Grand
he makes a year he makes more than that
as long as he played oh yeah really
okay but I know he has properties uh in
Florida they can't touch and his kids
are there yeah they sell you some
property dicey right yeah but even but
even but even even dude think how stupid
he is yeah see how much it is Jen think
how stupid he is even after they clearly
murdered those people right even after
getting away with that yeah years later
he [ __ ] him and goons trapped these
guys in a [ __ ] hotel room
25 Grand monthly payout yeah so so about
300 Grand a year
right more than that
because 10 would be 250 300 300 yeah 300
Grand there you go
stop not bad falling no but if you ever
had those properties and stuff yeah you
placed he plays golf he plays like ton
of golf I got his friends yeah uh only
as friends right no friends I think
there are people
I I would say because he talks about
that like has he paid his debt in one
word no sir no paid it for murder how
long ago was that 30 years ago
he served no time in prison Ryan paid
his debt he remember he served time for
kidnapping uh nine years not for the pre
he didn't he did like six years ago now
he was she's tried in civil court in
Civil Court he was found guilty and has
to pay I forget how many millions of
dollars to the gold family yeah but
never in federal he got away with it so
did he pay his dues no for merging two
people innocently people no one innocent
[ __ ] kid dude it's nuts yep
wow
yeah I forgot that he didn't really
actually do any time no he did none he
had trouble lost his money Public
Disgrace never you know that's not
enough for murdering people it's not
[ __ ] enough you know but obviously I
I don't know how many friends he has I
know you talked about that like but he
would appear but even Kim Kardashian's
father who's his best friend and lawyer
like a big time lawyer and came out of
retirement to represent him yeah
thought he did it is that right yeah yep
and remember he was friends with just
like realized after looking at the
evidence he was like this guy did it
well because he did a lie detector test
he was like I want to take a lie
detector test and like all right let's
do it and then he failed that and they
never it didn't show up in court wow and
then there's a book on it it's great
book I forget the name of it but uh
Kardashian the lawyer I think he said
within like two hours of being in the
when he was you know taken into custody
within two hours he said something to
him and uh Robert Kardashian was like oh
he [ __ ] did it
I never looked down the same damn
cause I don't know that that shows too
like uh I mean it's real it's not you'll
see on the FX series once he gets out he
throws a party at his house and like his
fan like his kids are there like his
mom's there but he's like looking around
the room and shows us in the book too on
the actual book but none of his actual
friends they're like we're out man like
you murdered that girl we're out and
he's like look around like I don't know
and he's [ __ ] he was all Hollywood
people
you say I don't know any of these people
and they try getting reservations at his
favorite restaurant he's been to for
like 20 years in Brentwood and like we
don't have a table dude he's like no
it's OJ and like no no we know who it is
we have a table for you anymore they
can't go to the same restaurant they
like everything shut down for him yeah
everything everything cameras
no you can't it was just too obvious
with DNA evidence and stuff it's like no
nuts those dude not so yeah all right
that whole thing's so that thing is dead
no yeah oops give her two people I
bought a sweater off his dad off uh Ron
Coleman's dad though looked like a very
sad man in Arizona oh yeah you said that
for a long time
I invited in my show
he didn't come on yeah he yeah anyway
yeah those are dark days well you and I
have a son don't we we have sons
I can't imagine not [ __ ] terrible man
no I yeah
well no it's it's beyond what you can
imagine like it'd be
when you have kids what
and somebody kills your kid
no no
it got dark it got dark guys we like to
bring things down there's a moment of
silence having the beard come on in come
on in here hello what do you got Jen
Christian Ronaldo decided to take
like a a leave of absence from actually
playing it's gonna get darker Brian
sorry dude speaking of kids dying yeah
it's actually a perfect segue yeah yeah
after he and his wife had uh lost their
son however at the Man U and Liverpool
game he was actually greeted with a
standing ovation from the audience for a
minute just showing their stuff let's
watch this and this shows you a bit
sports are bigger like life is bigger in
sports sometimes because Liverpool and
Manchester United hait each other
absolutely hate each other
you know it's he's the greatest to ever
do it be a messy so
he had twins and the baby boy didn't
survive but the girl dead yeah tragic
man did you ever see how high he can
jump you ever see that freak yeah
you ever seen his his caps are it's so
weird there's a soccer ball outside this
place where you can try to jump as high
as he did and it's nobody comes [ __ ]
close dude how about when uh this is
years ago look at his [ __ ] legs yeah
this is years ago he was uh about to be
late to practice and he said I forget
which Ferrari like a 455 or 458 and he's
flying it was in England I think he's
[ __ ] flying down the road and red
scarf flips it and but he didn't get
touched and just ran to practice still
made it look what about the car he's
like do whatever you want man they like
showed that him like totaling that
[ __ ] Ferrari was like another person
like buying a Snickers bar because it
makes so much money yeah he's like I'll
get another one I gotta make to practice
Yeah Beast yeah he's very special oh he
makes all the money he's so [ __ ]
special that just like that that ability
to keep that
sustain that for that level of ferocious
intensity like it's just a different
kind of guy man he's just different
he had a hat trick just the other week
did he really Patrick it means the worst
team in Premier League still that's what
still doing it still [ __ ] I know
well I knew he had a hat trick but I
mean you don't follow it yeah I followed
some like Jay's really into it but then
I knew he had a hat trick because it was
on the news and I told Patty that I'm
like Chris Chris Christian Oliver
Ronaldo's still [ __ ] doing it dude he
goes here's the hat trick against the
worst team in the league mate okay he's
like their [ __ ] team still three yeah
I mean yeah no sketching
boxer Amir Khan was leaving a restaurant
in East London the other night with his
wife when he actually got robbed at
gunpoint he said luckily his wife was a
few steps behind him so they didn't even
really notice that she was there and two
men jumped out of a car held him at
gunpoint for his watch and they jumped
back in a car this Mercedes is the car
that did it he was very upset about
losing a I forgot what it was a Frank
you know watches Frank um
senator Frank Moeller a Frank Muller
watch I guess it goes for about a
hundred thousand at least Jesus Christ
and some of my watch taken off me at
gunpoint in East London outside Sahara
Grill I crossed the road with his girl
luckily she was a few steps behind me
two men ran to me one hauling a gun from
far and one had the gun pointing to my
head asking for my watch the main thing
is we're both safe I posted the watch
and serial number in case it goes around
we can find out who's done this you
hopefully they catch him that's funny
they didn't catch them they did not
catch them as well Scott and the art
will catch him probably you say it's
inside job because like we didn't post
where we're at and these guys just jump
out
or they say coming in with that flashy
watch you know yeah it sounds like they
staged it you know they know where he is
I don't know [ __ ] you know someone
tipped them you're bringing so much
attention to yourself when you rob a
[ __ ] celebrity like that though I
don't know
yeah but those guys have nothing you see
that [ __ ] it's probably yeah two
three hundred thousand dollar watch
diamonds too crazy but such a special
watch not like there's so you can sell
that though on the black market oh my
God what oh because Black Market people
are gonna be like well this is I know
where this watch came from like anything
so is anybody gonna buy it oh yeah
they know you're going to give it back
though I mean like that that's a very
that looks like a very unique watch yeah
it is for sure I don't know wow
possible they didn't know what it was
um he's pretty [ __ ] famous
oh did you see Elon Musk tweet no I did
not I saw uh Mr Stefano promote his name
yeah that's so funny yeah yeah the
Stefano is so [ __ ] funny man because
we had this whole player we talked
months ago why we're all gonna say [ __ ]
Hollywood we're all gonna release on our
on YouTube and we're gonna do it three
weeks apart we'll promote each other
special and then I'm texting all the
ideas back and forth yeah yeah I know
that's cool man uh so I went with
Netflix
I get it [ __ ]
hey sorry man I'll see him uh in two
weeks in New York yeah he's the best
he's so funny when they say yes to his
special
uh just recently half hour or an hour
hour that's great he's a monster to me
Chris the finest guy in New York good
friend he's the best
that's amazing but elon's [ __ ] on
fire right now this report's first
subscriber loss it's because I got to be
honest when I go to Netflix they don't
have a lot of good shows they have a lot
of [ __ ] on there
you know you have a good amount of
movies that are geared towards a younger
audience I'm not sorry well like Ozarks
narcos is great yeah those dating shows
are cool I'm getting a little sick of
the dating show that they spent a lot of
money so you'd almost spent all the
money yeah so I think you gotta have
just more competition now with HBO Max
even well they were saying that they
only were they were only given they were
only given a couple of uh the awards you
know
um and they won a lot Awards uh scroll
down chip where it says wait so he
replied to Netflix he was basically like
this oh the woke narrative is not
working that's why you guys lost so many
is that what he said yeah let me see
there's another another example of this
woke narrative not working and they
fired didn't they fire a [ __ ] uh
langella for making a sexual joke I mean
you posted yesterday chin so this is
seven hours ago keep going
[Music]
um
boy tweets a lot huh this is a
H it's too late I don't know he I can't
believe you can't find it I want to see
it I'll just type in all on Netflix
reply yeah
Elon Musk Netflix reply
there you go the woke mind virus
is making Netflix unwatchable oh that
was one right there
crater 20 after company reports that
lost weight 10 years
wow the woke mind virus is making
Netflix unwatchable I agree with that
but because these with these what's
happening is these big corporations like
net Netflix and Disney right now they're
gonna learn the hard way is they're
tailoring toward this woke agenda
because of social media this is radical
yes it's radical correct tiny radical
and but they think because social media
is so loud and everyone's on they think
that social media speaks for the masses
it's not money it's not the money it's
not with the money the majority of
people aren't on there dude right so
when you're tailing it just towards that
crowd this is how you're going to learn
because so the mass mandate was lifted
in airports
I don't know a single person who's not
thrilled about it I agree and from even
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
thrilled if you tweet right now
tomorrow when you're on your flight to
Tampa thank God no Mass dude one out of
a thousand will be I'm with you man the
rest will just light you alive and some
of it might not even be real right well
who gives a [ __ ] even if it is it's but
it's not real that's doesn't that
doesn't represent the majority of people
in any facet that's right but online
that liberal woke thing to attack and
they're so loud Mass how dare you but
most of America the majority is like
yeah we've had enough dude we've had
enough [ __ ] off Airlines know what
they're doing their Airlines aren't
backing down to [ __ ] social to
Twitter no no they're like no we know
for our fact people [ __ ] hate you've
been saying that from day one I would
get caught up and you'd be like it's not
real not real man and it's not real it's
just not real you just stay the [ __ ] off
there's something to be said about that
if I didn't need to advertise on it and
[ __ ] around I I don't know I just well I
was talking to Bert about it right
because as far as stand-up goes he's the
best in in the world at promoting he
puts he has a high budget for he's a
great team like nobody's been promoting
anything than Bert Kreischer ever in
comedy don't care who you are nobody's
better and uh he's one of the best guys
too such a great person dude we could
have done a Five Hour podcast
we had to wrap it up early but
um
we were just talking about social media
and Instagram stuff like that I'm like
yeah posting ghosts but I don't see
anything he said I do for the most part
but I have to look at analytics to make
sure what I'm promoting is is working
he's like so I look at analytics every
now and then I look at comments but it's
whatever and uh I was just like yeah
dude you're always coming with stuff and
I go hey Bert it's exhausting isn't it
he goes I'm so glad you said that man he
said I constantly have to come with new
[ __ ] for [ __ ] social media man
but that's also you know he does he
continues to do it kind of new ideas and
has his team and that's why he sells 10
000 tickets on a Tuesday insert Market
where he sells 5 000 tickets at 9 30 a.m
in [ __ ] New York where they drink
beer and watch me stand up like he's a
[ __ ] monster that's incredible yeah
so juice is worth the squeeze man I I
think so
I think so if you went to his house
she's like I'll do that yeah oh I'll do
it yeah yeah
uh Port Charlotte visani theater this
weekend guys starting tomorrow dude
that's just as good as Bert dude Port
Charlotte we are gonna blow it out dude
dude in that market and then I got
Charlotte then I got Wise Guys the next
one these guys yeah that's great yeah
that's a great Market Thursday Friday
Saturday uh what am I promote oh just
the special drops next Thursday April
28th you hear me on Rogan dropping the
special the Gringo poppy on thick boy
YouTube only and after that uh May
5th 6th and seventh I'm in uh Charlotte
Comedy Zone Charlotte I like that place
a lot trash Panda tour I like starts out
I like that trash Panda yep
um
I'll be in Stress Factory uh New Jersey
May 5th 6th 7th yeah I'm excited I
haven't done that place I like these
short flights you're doing but I'm not
one to talk [ __ ] because I go
to New York Charlotte and from Charlotte
back to L.A I have like two weeks off
and then I go [ __ ] to Philly it's a
lot Beast it's a lot now you're doing
helium yeah I feel like my favorite uh
and my boys at suplex right there I
can't wait they're great guys ah the
best yeah they're the ones that provide
all the shoes for food truck Diaries we
have a deal together it's great I just
got Gilbert uh burn shoe size
unfortunately I didn't get Patty shoes
or Alex volkanovsky because they're so
short notice they're in Philly so they
couldn't ship them in time so they're
the first food trucks we found on a
thick boy where they didn't get shoes
makes me sad it's all right Patty could
use them Patty's gonna give a [ __ ] about
fashion no he was mate this is all free
he's like what are you spending money in
this food yeah cars how about this watch
these are nice I bought this that's
about it I wouldn't close anything it's
all free the shoes everything these
shorts in Liverpool you can't give a
[ __ ] around looking like you get stabbed
I mean he could you know punched yeah
you could
for him
what a sketching all right
so I saw this
Russia tested a nuclear missile that
apparently Putin says is the best in the
world and no one's it's not comparable
to any other missile not for a long time
I bet we have better this is what he
says exactly you know what before you
read this you know what's interesting to
me is the Johnny Depp Amber Heard trials
going on right now I watched it I
watched some of it yeah also here's the
I'm a Johnny Depp fan dude him in Black
Mass top three favorite movies of all
time love black mass love them
he's he's born and raised in Kentucky
yeah why are you talking like you're
British all the time well you know I
think uh where's the accent you know I
think happened spent a lot of time
studying addiction and uh yeah it's
social am I strange words you're born in
country because Kentucky has the worst
memories and I think he got the [ __ ] out
of there and 30 years later but then he
but then you're born and raised in
[ __ ] Hollywood at a young age because
he's around 21 Jump Street because when
you were an actor you have to get rid of
your Kentucky accent and you have to
speak like that neutrally yes that same
in neutral he's also around but that's
you know a very educated people you know
it's an affectation you know you I think
it is yeah he got way too into Jack
Sparrow he did way too many [ __ ] well
what was the yeah he's always been it
was just like [ __ ] I'm wearing
scarves mascara yeah he reinvented
himself with the the whole look and
everything he's always dressed that way
though he looks cool yeah it's just the
accent I'm like what are you Tommy from
Kentucky dude and if you're not from
Kentucky from L.A why are you talking
like that now you you're good at this
you're good at predicting things I feel
like Amber Heard looks very bad in this
oh yeah right yeah like you you start
doing crazy you start to go wait you
took advantage of this me too thing in
2017 now it's biting you in the ass
because you weren't abused it sounds
like you were the abuser he was hiding
and I believe him me too I don't believe
her I think she's so ambitious that we
also have a friend who knows them yeah
and we've heard stories yeah there's
that there is that right I've always
heard that though even before I've heard
she's just a you know tough cookie she's
crazy the tough cookie or unethical or
willing to do whatever it takes and step
on anybody to I also know a lot of
people like that
um you know who I happen to be actors or
actresses and uh we'll do that so you're
starting to see this it's really really
interesting
but she [ __ ] in his back yeah he's
accusing her [ __ ] in the bed because
she blamed it on the dog but he was like
it's way too big for a dog their little
dog to produce see this makes her look
so bad dude it's so hard to get away
from this now remember why he's sooner
so remember it was a as a basically a me
too saying she was abused and she put it
in whatever the sun in England and it
ruined his career yeah and then she also
did it again out here I think and that's
why so he lost the trial in England
which cost him so much yeah because that
was a defamation trial against the sun
yes they called him a wife beater
they're [ __ ] which really [ __ ] with
no evidence but I was watching the trial
and he was saying you know Ops I signed
up for this with Fame and stuff like
that but you know it's not fair no
matter how you feel about celebrities
it's not fair that these major media
Outlets can write whatever they want
whether it's true or not and I just have
to deal with it he's like it's not fair
at the same time about church in the
vaccency
as absurd
and grotesque how embarrassing is this
and
you talk so slow he's so slow yeah dude
you gotta hurry up from Kentucky spread
it out and I was shown a picture
of what the problem was I had gone to Mr
bet
and said uh
she's in culture she's a Coachella I
think it's a good time to go downtown
so that I can get some of my things you
know
and get them out of there especially the
things that were
precious to me you know Hunter Thompson
now is a good time to go be a photograph
does he show pictures dookie I don't
know
objection
it's a photograph your honor
as being relayed to him by Mr bet he
says he looked at it on his on his phone
I'll rule the objection as the
photograph nice
what was the photograph of Mr death
[Music]
take your time
take your time
it was a
it's all laughing look at how long he
takes there's a photograph of the bed
our bed
um and on
my side is the bed come on Johnny
um
was human fecal matter
fecal matter his vocabulary is great um
so I understood why it wasn't a good
time to go down there
um
dude my initial response to that was
I mean I laughed
it was so
outside
it was so bizarre
and so grotesque
that I could only laugh
dude um he's laying it down
and um
so I did not go down there that day
well
so she wanted to stick her finger in the
cage and now you're now what happens is
you're you're in a court of law and they
start asking you all the details and the
questions and you you didn't think about
this
you didn't think about this yeah you
didn't think you know what I mean he's
in my debut this is
dude they're good at this they're the
best they're the best they've been doing
this for you're in Hammond you're white
belt bro you're now you're on a map with
a Blackboard you don't and you think
you've covered all your bases and then
they start getting into the details and
the problem with anytime you make up a
story or you lie is you got to remember
all the lies when you tell the truth you
have to remember one story that's the
great thing about telling the truth you
know you you tell you you only have one
story to remember when you're a liar
you've got a toxic was their [ __ ]
relationship oh my God they sound both
she sounds like a just I don't know what
the [ __ ] was going on there she sounds
like she's super damaged and that was as
dysfunctional as it gets and he does
sound like he was abused he talks about
that and he says she weaponized that
against them I believe him yeah I just I
think she's frustrated he thinks he's a
pirate that might be it could be that
like dude give up the pirate but that is
but her mistake was she should have left
it alone and her mistake was going bad
then she said she'd give money to to a
charity and she didn't give any of the
money you know she shows how bad of a
person she is what he's dealing with
she's he should be okay in this one I
hope so me too this affects this affects
her career now
she's in some trouble yeah a little
career she had though even he talks
about that she didn't have much of a
career right he talks about that he's
like I don't know if it's a jealousy
thing like obviously he's crushed and
doing Pirates of the Caribbean 19 or
whatever the [ __ ] he's doing tonight
then he's in the [ __ ] whatever where
he's playing a wizard you know and they
took him from that fantastic Beast
fantastic Beast
she's just one of those people that
seems to date very strategically and and
does whatever she can to get herself
and I I have no I'm very you know me I'd
be a terrible cop I'm very forgiving of
things but I seeing what people will do
to get them their names and their faces
in the Limelight and they don't give a
[ __ ] it never works out it's never
anybody with talent that does this
though if you notice anybody who they
want to [ __ ] on others well you don't
get away critique others it's so short
side like you might get a pop at first
then career-wise the fans aren't going
to follow it because you're not very
talented you're not gonna follow up you
don't get away ultimately with anything
no it doesn't give anybody
in any way and I don't know I don't know
all the details but I believe Jason
Momoa is testifying against her too
because they work together on Aquaman
and he is uh trying to get her kicked
off that franchise and replaced with
Emilia Clark because she's crazy yeah
she's so dip She's so different you know
they called in [ __ ] Elon Musk because
he was hooking up with
he said that too
uh what Elon did yeah I don't know if he
said that
I was trying to help the case here you
just made that up maybe that's fine well
they didn't work out though she's crazy
because she's crazy
yeah I believe he was put on the stand
to confirm or deny whether they were
having an affair while Johnny Depp for
her which they were he confirmed it like
a robot there you go right yes I had sex
yep there you go and then I took off in
a jet oh he denied it yeah
well if she's okay let's then I he's
like let's deny this and then what are
you gonna do yeah
wow shout out to Elon Musk do you want
to see Johnny's finger dude yeah please
she cut his finger she oh that's what he
said she did it no no she threw a vodka
bottle right at it when he's at his bar
and then I tried to block you no he was
just hanging out like this and then the
bottle just smashed through his hands
and he actually cut the tip off
with him there it is oh I know that's
insane she cut his finger off the tip is
[ __ ] huh but then they were able to
attach it again so damn dude there are
actually videos of him doing a press
junket for a movie where his finger is
like he had it stitched back together
and his co-stars were like what happened
see there he has two balls deep in the
pirate scheme you see see how he has the
[ __ ] eyeliner on like Jack I love
Jack Sparrow I don't mind it at all I
dig it and he got the Jack Sparrow stuff
it's been a rather uh interesting dude
we've been famous for 40 years
you're gonna be a little weird wow look
at that finger [ __ ] dude oh so you can't
oh that's a tough relationship she is
good gorgeous you know she's got that
not anymore
no no she looks like crazy on the stand
yeah yeah and whenever he says something
she's like writing some down she just
looks like it I think she's I think she
realized that she's she's in over her
head you [ __ ] decided to get some
Fame by going bad on him and saying that
he beat you when now we start to see the
truth and we all go oh wait a minute but
I I guess too that's her understanding
she's pretty hot there it's very hot but
I but on but I guess you know the
defamation lawsuit obviously so if he
wins this does he expect Hollywood to
invite him back he'll make money off her
what money does she have he has all the
money no she's got some money still he
has all the money yeah no and you know
judgment he's talking about how he paid
for all her [ __ ] but when you get a
judgment if you have seven million
dollars in the bank whatever you have
that he gave to her when you have a
judgment against you you got to sell
your house whatever you make in the
future you're going to be paying him yes
oh it's a you don't want to lose this
reputation on Aquaman so I'm sure that
pays a couple Mills reputationally you
don't want to lose it but what I'm
saying the way I don't know I don't know
Hollywood you know they're so [ __ ]
weird if you were to win this this
Hollywood like okay come on back
I don't know like using the Fantastic
Beast I think it's Johnny Depp he got
replaced yeah I know but I think I think
I think I think I think he's gonna win I
think also he's gonna come back I think
he's Johnny Depp that promise that's not
the problem the promise his movies don't
make money that's the big problem the
problem is that most of his movies
Forbes ran an article and said for every
dollar you put into a Johnny Depp movie
you for every hundred dollars you put
into a Johnny Depp movie you get one
dollar back that was a big thing I don't
know it's been some big that's a fact
that's a fact the only movies that made
money for a long time it might be
because now his Jack Sparrow his demand
so big yeah the Pirates Caribbean yeah
but otherwise
Fantastic Beasts that he's made tons of
money I don't think so
650 million dollars yeah because he
would do things like shoot Hunter
Thompson's ashes out of Cannon for two
million dollars oh that's fun yeah
there's all kinds of crazy things uh
mini TV series you guys are trying to
work uh okay got a little weird after
once it started going down
see the Fantastic Beasts was a huge hit
but he was the villain in that
um he did work with chin on Rango yeah
keep going down chin
uh man it's been tough lately you're not
lying Brian well Pirates of the
Caribbean dead Man tells no lies I'm
huge was it that was the one fantastic
Beast was a hit Alice uh one line was a
huge hit yeah Black Mass the best movie
ever Mordecai was good ooh black mask
was a good movie oh dude dude Dark
Shadows fantastic
yeah a black mass literally top three
for me I will watch it once a month
yeah well I played Boston
in October I think or maybe uh September
and I'm I'm the the bar that uh Whitey
Bulger hung out and I talked to Steve
he's called like some O's I'm gonna go
there there you go all right I'm gonna
get shanked
wow you think you have Whitey Bulger
merch what else you got what else Whitey
Bulger merch yeah they don't sell white
Bulls too much you guys were talking
about this earlier so ASAP Rocky was
detained at LAX because of a tie to a
shooting that apparently the suspect or
the victim says that he ASAP Rocky shot
at him four times and then graze his
hand what yeah and this happened in
November 2021 and it never made the news
team's good I never made the news whoa
until now
does the guy have any proof they just
retain the guy they must have proof they
have to have enough yeah something
I mean just the guys to hang out hit and
he did out of the plane like [ __ ] I
wonder if that's true though I don't I
don't know
I mean did he really do that
yeah no idea but he did get detained
interesting yeah
um lucky ASAP
she's got a tough week yeah
um this is just an update to the Dwayne
Haskell stuff to read this when I saw
the headline and then my [ __ ] my kids
you know getting ready for school and
forget it yeah so is that what would she
say his wife called the police and said
that he called her and that he ran out
of gas so he's gonna get more gas for
his car and then he kind of just went
out went off and never answered her
phone after that
you were suspect of this ombre thinking
of suicide it is strange like that
highway feels like a dump truck like
it's not like it's a small Miata that
hit him a dump truck at that speed yeah
with his athleticism probably two two to
three cars hit him first the dump truck
and then the other cars hit him yeah
that'll do it I don't know I think you
might find that his car is not out of
gas yeah and then so this call is just
too long and it's a woman just crying
and saying like get out of get on the
street get out the street go straight
and then finally he got hit by a dump
truck this and that so it seems like he
yeah you would imagine he's kind of
because she's young like what are you
doing yeah that makes me sad yeah I
wonder what's going on with him yeah
some people it's such a shame man you
never I mean what a way to go though too
this is yeah this is I don't know I mean
who knows CT I'm sure maybe who knows
who knows the CT or he just maybe he's
always suffered from depression but then
also remember
he got and it's not you know nobody's
fault he got catapulted into super
stardom when he really only played a
year of college ball and then they told
him not to go the NFL like you're not
ready yet and he's like nah [ __ ] that
I'm going gets drafted not ready has a
terrible year I think with directions so
you know so you're getting [ __ ] on all
the time you're the the leader of their
franchise it's not going well and then
after a year being drafted in the first
round that Washington Redskins where if
you make a bad choice it sets your team
back four years
I have four years if that gets supposed
to be the facial franchising he's a
piece you know he's not very good and
you set your franchise back especially
as a starting quarterback so then he
think about how much money they invested
in Haskins doesn't work out after a year
be they send him to the [ __ ] Steelers
it's like a backup wow he's playing
there wow well Senator backups we can
learn and kind of no they're like we're
all set dude we're good after a year
yeah like at least let me know in the
system
and that means they thought he was a
prom and saw no potential is that right
no 100 yeah because they invested
millions of dollars in it wow you got
the investment and they just cut their
losses yeah we're like we're good we'll
move on after a year which is unheard
unheard of even if you guys bad it's on
her see that's the thing I don't know
about it and then we're good his mind
he's like oh [ __ ] I'm I'm screwed yeah
because when you're from starter to back
up so you're not getting the same
attention anymore wow so men and let's
say you suffer from depression that's
really gonna [ __ ] with you and then
imagine if you are the star quarterback
on the Redskins they weren't winning
they're off at the time so you think
social media was friendly to him
so he's dealing with that on top of
depression oh my God nobody invest in it
you [ __ ] get to the Steelers you're a
backup I'm sure you're still getting
[ __ ] online you know chance of become a
starter is not good this wasn't your you
know they told you not to go yet you
decide to Bank in yourself didn't work
out yeah horrible dude they wanted to
stay an extra year just to learn the
game more and because he only had a year
of experience he came off the bench he's
you just you know what I mean in college
at Ohio State he just had one good year
so it's happened before with like
Jamarcus Russell's really had one good
game in the Sugar Bowl just through deep
balls and like he's the next [ __ ]
Boomer Sison yeah and he's not and they
put all this money in and even JaMarcus
Russell got more [ __ ] leniency than
Haskins damn because that means in the
in the training room and stuff he wasn't
watching film or nothing really like oh
he doesn't even have the discipline he
says team way back look at the Redskins
do they [ __ ] suck if they're worth so
much money they have a huge payroll this
should be good yeah
the top five most valuable teams and
they're the worst out of the top five
[ __ ]
yeah that's the inside baseball scoop
inside football yep what else you got
you inside football inside baseball do
you mind if I do a current event that's
personal sure okay so I was involved in
a hit and run Oh I thought you would do
something on us like no no no no no wait
we're in the headline dude you're gonna
hit and run recently yeah so I was able
to record her hitting you and running no
it's not not that part by recorded
Witnesses saying like yeah she hit you
so you know I got their cards where did
this happen at chin right next to my
apartment at a Shell gas station was it
your fault you think
she reversed into me and I kept honking
I'm like stopped up
all right smash what ethnicity was she
black
hey man you just hit my car I got your I
got your license plate that's your
license plate
and what damage did she do my whole left
corner she just hit it and was like see
you dude yeah she just bounced and then
when you said something she saved her
camera that she hit my car she hit your
car yeah if she hits your car you can no
I trust that guy get the police report
yeah yeah they said that the cameras and
everything once I get the police report
done I already filed it yeah and they
have the license she's fine yeah but I'm
hoping someone could freaking find her
so I could do what I don't know how bad
was the uh I mean it's gonna cost a lot
of money for sure like how bad is the
damage it's uh the back left part so the
quarter panel and the bumper I didn't
get the lights broken so she hit my side
not my yeah she's probably going what
five miles
I actually had a back pain afterwards
because it twisted me oh that's why I
was gonna say on that how we started on
the Johnny Depp Amber Heard situation
which it's interesting sure there's a
legit war going on dude they stopped all
of that to [ __ ] air Johnny Depp
talking about Amber Heard [ __ ]
although I will say this for the it's
good to make sense it's it's it is
important in some ways because
there are people taking advantage of
this new movement and and if she is
that's that's bad so and is it more
important than Ukraine no but I do think
it's newsworthy it does have
ramifications that go beyond I put it at
the bottom though you know and then keep
the huge stars of war no I know I get it
I get it take it right away like this
most people don't like he's like [ __ ]
this I'm actually gonna fight it most
people do not you're spending so much
money the one he lost in the UK is now
this is and all the Press like it's she
doesn't want this press this is so bad
like now people like you took a [ __ ] in
his bed there there's already she's
known as [ __ ] girl she's nice
yeah I mean that's that's pretty
gangster I'm gonna take a [ __ ] where you
sleep imagine just bending over and
taking a [ __ ] out of bed difficult to do
in the first passive [ __ ] that's
impressive I think I was in diarrhea God
damn who knows they were probably firm
anyway yeah it was a coil it was like it
was like a snake yeah but you you would
but I would like my nose is so sensitive
as soon as I walk in the room like as
soon as oh my God some [ __ ] in here
right away I wouldn't be like what is
this I wouldn't get in bed no I remember
I had this puppy in college I told this
story and he was a little pit bull named
uh Pig we call him Piglet and you know
he's a puppy
we always have to wear the CU football
issue gear and after we're doing dirty
dozen set to wake up at 5am to go to
[ __ ] conditioning and it's freezing
outside tossing my hoodie and I'm
driving hating my life it's so [ __ ]
miserable I'm like it smells like
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude this car smells like
[ __ ] and I'm like soap because my nose
has always been sensitive I'm like this
is ridiculous I'm like it's in my
[ __ ] whatever driving driving I go to
get other car and one of my buddies goes
hey dude what's in your [ __ ] sweater
I'm like what he goes what's on your
hoodie I look down and I must have
stepped on it there was a a [ __ ] pile
of [ __ ] on my just just [ __ ]
etched into my oh dude it smelled
horrendous but I was out of it I'm so
tired it's five in the morning I'm doing
this I'm doing I'm with my buddy and I'm
doing my Spanish dancing thing in his
apartment and he just goes dude what the
[ __ ] stinks I had dog [ __ ] all over my
feet all over my shoes oh while you're
dancing and there's nothing like
the smell of [ __ ] I remember right when
we were young we had these cats my dad
uh told me they ran away he just threw
him in the canal anyway uh we love these
cats but the cat the big mom cat she was
like a tabby [ __ ] behind the TV and my
we my dad would take us to like uh I can
smell that the video store and we'd
always pick a video it was a Friday
night so me and my brother and my dad
would I've never eat this we had this
big like pillow and we'd always lean on
it and watch the TV maybe watching this
movie and my dad's like when you fart no
and Jay's like no not at all and then my
dad's nose is more sensitive than mine
he gets like I can't wear clone around
my dad I'll freak the [ __ ] out sore
watch it and he's like who is farting
and I'm like that I did not fart I swear
to God she said I did not fart he's like
oh [ __ ] that hits play and the only
reason is eating our [ __ ] whatever
twist or something my dad's like stop
some movies all right you two whoever's
[ __ ] farting I'm telling you if you
don't stop we're not We're not gonna
finish the movie I'm gonna stop moving
right now like we're not farting
he's like I'm telling you one more time
we're gonna stop watching a movie We're
Not Gonna farting hits play a minute
later he's like you know what you know
what because you know you smell like
[ __ ] he's like you know what I'm I'm
done with this takes the movie out me my
brother crying and then I'm like it does
smell like [ __ ] but we don't know it's
coming behind the TV I don't know if the
cat ate
something dude you're talking uh
rhinoceros mound of cat [ __ ] just clear
hard and then just all all sauces just
on them my dad apologized to us we got
to finish the movie after scrubbing this
card after Scruff this is carpet daddy
that's a bad carpet is it never quite
leaves it never quite leaves dude [ __ ]
throw the carpet away dude even if
you're wiping ass you just you know your
thumb sometimes just graze your [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying they just graze
this
this is your [ __ ] for the Day Disaster
oh what soap are you gonna use dude
disaster no you need rubbing alcohol
like normal soap won't get you go to the
hospital have the musical so I mean the
entire day like mom's gonna be [ __ ] guy
yeah I just I mean just happy you know
you just [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and you'll feel
it you're like oh [ __ ] is horrible oh
it's impossible to get off yep sometimes
you can have sex and somebody doesn't
practice the property oh you can smell
it and they'll just you'll be like well
yeah the undercarriage that's a big
problem the hot undercarriage [ __ ] come
on ladies I don't like it talking about
gay guys two guys who really don't give
a [ __ ] one as a dirty pooper I think
they have to care tell me not all
there's a couple Bears out there I'm
sure a couple guys
just dirty truck drivers dingleberries
oh the smell net truck man dude the
smell of beef jerky big gulps and ass
yeah in that truck yeah
I don't know
yeah I don't know so poop's terrible all
right good good we're we're covering
good ground here us being a covering
good ground April 28th next Thursday my
special drops the Gringo poppy yeah on
thick boy YouTube only get you some 30
minutes of pure [ __ ] Fury
and uh for the road dates uh by the time
you're listening so I'll be on stage at
The Improv that is sold out our night
sold out show at shop and Friends we'll
have another one next month so don't cry
uh Charlotte North Carolina May 5th
through the 7th at the comedy zone in
Charlotte North Carolina and then Philly
is May 19th through May 21st so get your
tickets at fatkz.com also next week
thick boy Fight Club Church drop and the
Gringo poppy shirts just for my special
drop as well on thickboy.com it'll be
all over my social media also next
Thursday drops Chin's part of this the
thick Boy album that chin jelly roll
Mike Stud Chris D'Elia Eric Griffin uh
Mark Harley Mark Harley Chappelle hello
Bros little brows I think Stevie's on
there a ton of people on this album and
I just post on my Instagram the last
album that we did with little brows went
over like a million uh [ __ ] streams
so they sent him a dope ass plaque wow
so shout out to little brows man awesome
yeah there's my guy that's amazing look
at that
wow
yeah pretty cool right million streams
wow but man the jelly roll song and
[ __ ]
oh just crushed it absolutely the little
brows is so goddamn talented it's unreal
I just want him to get big enough where
he can't make thick Boy albums anymore
love it yep poor Charlie Sonic theater
comic theater uh this weekend Las Vegas
Nevada Wise Guys Comedy Club New
Brunswick New Jersey Stress Factory then
I got the DC comedy law that'd be fun uh
May 12th the 14th May 19th I'm shooting
my special at the brand improv okay God
I wish I was here for that buddy [ __ ] oh
the Cowboys fight companion May 7th I'll
be in Charlotte but boy do we have a
special show for you guys we got Matt
mitrione Rashad Evans and Rampage
Jackson it's a tough 10 alumni without
me wow
there you go yep that would be a thick
boy for the big UFC May 7th first one
I'll miss man sorry guys is that it all
right the Gringo poppy drops April 28th
Thursday thick boy YouTube 30 minutes of
pure fire lighting up my Latin family
all right guys love you this is a
throwback episode hopefully you enjoyed
it fighter and the kid